in this country the department of
transportation is pushing new measures
to recruit more truck drivers the
american trucking association says the
u.s needs another 80 000 truckers the
shortage has worsened the supply chain
crisis and first on cbs morning's errol
barnett spoke with transportation
secretary pete butterjudge about this
errol good morning to you
hey there good morning you know we can
thank truck drivers like the one you see
behind me for moving 72 percent of goods
throughout the country every day but the
industry is approaching a breaking point
retention rates are very low the driver
supply is also rapidly dwindling and
that's why transportation secretary buda
judge tells cbs news he is making
retaining drivers and keeping them
incentivizing them to stay on the road a
top priority
empty store shelves signal a supply
chain in crisis
exacerbated by a shortage of truck
drivers what is your reaction to seeing
grocery store shelves bear were you
shocked by that oh i'm very concerned
about this and it reflects the fact that
as long as we go through phase after
phase of this pandemic we're seeing
disruptions in supply transportation
secretary pete buda butterjudge spoke to
cbs news as his agency announces new
efforts to bolster the number of
truckers as part of the biden
administration's pledge to fix the
supply chain
announcing thursday more than 32 million
dollars for states to improve the
commercial drivers licensing process
over 100 companies committing to expand
trucking apprenticeship programs and a
task force to investigate predatory
truck leasing we've got to recruit more
people into the job and we've got to
keep them there drivers have been
fleeing in droves with yearly turnover
hitting 90 percent in parts of the
trucking industry if the wheels aren't
rolling these guys aren't making any
money mickey weaver's company connects
trucking applicants with employers not
only are there too few job seekers he
says once they see how much time in the
truck is unpaid many quit i hadn't seen
a guy just this morning he'd been
sitting up for three to four hours just
sitting there just waiting to get his
truck loaded and he's not making any
money you're basically paying the
company for the privilege of picking up
a load patrick penfield is a professor
of supply chain practice at syracuse
university and believes better pay
structures would fix backlogs but until
you do that these poor truckers are kind
of at the mercy of these ports these
other destinations where they have to
wait secretary buda judge says that's
one idea they are studying we need to
look at these compensation issues if we
really want to solve long-term
challenges in trucking in the us
now the administration's new effort also
includes two studies of what's called
detention time that's the label for when
drivers are on the job but not being
paid the pay-per-mile plan effectively
encourages drivers to move extra long
distances often to the point of their
own extra exhaustion it is not an easy
job
uh they sound like they need to be
addressed arrow truckers are the
lifeblood for all americans thank you
very much as always appreciate it